bonsoir françois rebsamen avant soit
efficacité des services publics
économies à terme mais on l'a entendu un
coup pour cette initiative d'ailleurs
c'est ce que dénonce l'opposition
municipale est ce que c'est bien le
moment de dépenser autant d'argent
si l'opposition municipale travaillaient
les dossiers elle serait qu' on ne
dépense pas autant d'argent l'argent que
nous allons dépenser en investissement
c'est de l'argent que nous aurions de
toute façon des pensées car il était
évident que il fallait moderniser tout
ce qui est sur la voirie tous les
instruments de la voix république il
faut moderniser par exemple les feux il
faut permettre aux bus ou tram de passer
avec un signal particulier donc il faut
moderniser mondiale à dijon on a envie
de dire pourquoi dijon mais pourquoi des
gens parce qu'on est innovant et parce
que la métropole de dijon est repéré
comme un lieu d'innovation mais pas de
l'innovation pour l'innovation de
l'innovation pour les habitants des
avantages pour les habitants je ne je ne
supporte pas que l'opposition puisse
dire des choses qui sont fausses
si on veut débattre démocratiquement il
faut partir de choses qui sont réelles
alors ce matériel va faire les économies
formidable mais vous savez on va à moyen
terme non très rapidement au fur à
mesure de nos investissements
on va changer trente quatre mille points
lumineux on va avoir des leds
intelligent c'est à dire des lumières
intelligent qui vont s'allumer plus
fortement quand tu en avoir besoin et
main quand on meurt à personne et qui le
demandera quand on marchera comme ne
marchera pas sur l'espace public
donc tout ça c'est des économies
formidable qui vont être réalisés et
toutes ces économies vont être
réinjectés dans des investissements
nouveau ce matin vous avez inauguré
cette métropole intelligente avec un
parterre de grands patrons d'entreprises
privées alors est-ce que vous remettez
les libertés publiques entre les mains
des chefs d'entreprises privées oui
c'est d'ailleurs assez étonnant de voir
qu'on pourrait critiquer les grandes
entreprises françaises parce que
bouygues edf suez capgemini c'est des
plus grands ingénieurs français qui sont
rassemblés dans ces quatre grandes
entreprises et nous ce que nous
proposons c'est l'économie mixte
l'économie mixait le service public qui
se modernise qui continue d'être en
responsabilité mais qui est aidé et
accompagné par les ingénieurs du privé
pas antinomique avec des valeurs de
gauche
on ne vit pas on ne vit pas à l'époque
du gosplan aujourd'hui on a donc des
entreprises qui gère pour le compte de
la collectivité qui reste maîtresse de
ses investissements parler de liberté
publique françois rebsamen
il ya un centre de pilotage qui va
piloter les caméras de vidéosurveillance
etc qui va tout savoir sur notre vie
est-ce que c'est sous contrôle de
manière éthique est ce que vous avez
pris des garde-fous bien sûr notamment
les protection des données individuelles
et puis je vais faire je vais faire
mettre en place un comité où il y aura
des usagers des citoyens tout simplement
des universitaires des juristes qui
pourront vérifier à tout moment qu'il ya
la protection des libertés individuelles
c'est une pour un homme de gauche comme
moi c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'absolument et laisse penser alors
restez avec nous françois rebsamen parce
que l'actualité est riche il y à vous
avez déclenché une polémique
vous ne souhaitez pas que la prochaine
édition de florissimo se tiennent à
dijon et la réaction ne s'est pas fait
attendre le président de l'association
dijon congrexpo s'est exprimé ce matin
devant la presse jean battault dénonce
une méthode inacceptable je vous propose
de voir ce reportage signé caroline
jouerait et rodolfo j je n'en peux plus
du digeon trop riche pour bashing c'est
véritablement insupportable pourquoi
tant de haine le président de contre
expo pose la question il avance un début
d'explication
j'ai refusé certaines exigences
exprimées par le maire lors des
négociations de dsp l'exigence qui était
contre nature qui était illégale hors du
champ de la dsp une délégation de
service public
un contrat qui donne la gestion des
bâtiments propriété de la ville à congre
expo dijon qui organise des événements
depuis 1921 la fois gastronomique
internationale aujourd'hui la cinquième
de france en légère perte de vitesse
parce que c'est une foire qui sont le
graillon a dit françois rebsamen lors
d'un conseil municipal
pourquoi la foire sont voyons pas ce que
le maire qui en a la charge
j'aimais 1000 et les aérateurs qui était
nécessaire donc on veut pas ce nul ne
peut se prévaloir de ses propres
turpitudes
on peut pas reprocher à quelqu'un
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas fait soi
même
nous faisons nous avec les bâtiments
tels que la mairie de l'emea nos
dispositions florissimo initiée par le
premier ministre de l'environnement
robert poujade dans les années 1980 a
attiré 185 mille visiteurs en 2015 un
énorme succès mais françois rebsamen
souhaite remporter l'édition 2001 un
accord ou verbales nous avait donné par
monsieur demers l'an dernier pour la
tenue de florissimo comme ça se fait
depuis 40 ans au mois de mars 2020 et
même d'ailleurs précisant première
quinzaine le maire a expressément
demandé vous l'avons accepté que cette
manifestation se considérer comme
obligatoire dans la convention de
délégation de service public signé avec
la mairie donc très naturellement
puisqu'il nous faut il ya après la de
trois à quatre ans pour préparer pour
préparer une telle manifestation
nous avons engagé des frais cent mille
euros pour lesquels disons qu'on re expo
compte bien engager une procédure de
demande d'indemnisation françois
rebsamen les accusations de jean
battault sont graves
il dit que vous avez fait des demandes
illégales qui ne auxquels ils ne
pouvaient pas accéder aujourd'hui c'est
quoi le problème entre lui et vous le
problème c'est que dijon congrexpo qui
gère le parc des expositions fait de
gros bénéfices et ne veut pas investir
pour moderniser l'outil est donc c'est
assez traditionnelle entre un
propriétaire et locataire
jeudi c'est du devoir du locataire et 10
est du devoir du propriétaire
donc voilà le différentes pour concrètes
pour l'horizon c'est autre chose pour
florissimo il ya des nouvelles
dispositions qui aujourd'hui pénalise la
ville d'abord je voudrais dire que ce
sont les services de la ville qui
organise florissimo c'est pas c'est pas
un congrès expo et ça n'est pas que ça
soit comptabilisé dans vos comptes de
campagne
les élections à csmc comptabilisé d'ores
et déjà dans à partir du moment où les
services de la ville interviennent dans
la limitation que le gouvernement nous
impose à 1,2 pour cent des dépenses de
fonctionnement ce qui n'était pas le cas
précédemment
c'est un coût qui est en partie
remboursée par contre expo mais ça ne
change rien au fait que ce sont des
dépenses qui nous sont imputées
directement les serainement comme ça
n'existe plus comme à devenir le
j'ai pas dit qui il existe plus
définitivement j'ai dit qu'il fallait
changer la nature de congrès ce pot
c'est fini les fleurs coupées
c'est plus à la mode les fleurs coupées
on n'aimait pas les fleurs et vous
n'avez pas le graillon on est là on est
dans l'écologie on est dans l'écologie
et l'écologie aujourd'hui c'est une
manière durable de présenter les choses
et puis c'est vrai que ça son crayon la
foire est la foire mercure et si il y à
une baisse de fréquentation c'est du
hasard mais tout le monde le sait tous
nés à la question sur l'actualité
françois rebsamen
enfin je voudrais quand même dire que
jean battault ferait bien de faire
attention à ses propos
un mot sur les gilet jaune et la
nouvelle manifestation annoncée samedi
des manifestations interdites à lyon et
à paris on vient de l'apprendre
est ce que vous vous demander au préfet
de bourgogne de côte-d'or d'interdire la
manifestation de samedi puisque vous
avez déjà fait par votre agacement à
plusieurs objets rendez-vous ce plus qu
un agacement c'est insupportable c'est
inacceptable de s'attaquer ainsi aux
bâtiments publics à nos centres villes
qui est classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco à la préfecture au personnel
donc il y a là une atteinte aux libertés
publiques à la république et donc je
rencontre le préfet demain il va me
faire le point de la situation pour
samedi
et s'il le faut je lui demanderais
effectivement d'interdire cette
manifestation mais interdire pour
interdire il faut réussir à interdire et
c'est ça la plus difficile si françois
rebsamen d'avoir été avec